[Musique]
bonjour
tout le temps
je m'appelle Sébastien je suis français
Lulu c'est ma femme elle est chinoise
nous habitons à Pékin
on va se filmer comme ça pendant un an
tu es d'accord
mais j'ai pas de
vie privée toute façon
[Musique]
se taire en Chine c'est plus qu'une
habitude c'est un mode de survie
a priori chez moi il n'y a pas de caméra
espion mais parfois il y aurait vraiment
de quoi devenir paranoïaque
[Musique]
tu as pris les clés c'est toi qui prends
bienvenue chez nous
dans notre appartement au nord de Pékin
c'est toi qui prend les clés en bordure
du quatrième périphérique
c'est ici que je vis avec Lulu
je suis journaliste en Chine depuis 2016
nous menons une vie de couple ordinaire
un détail près
nous ne sommes jamais vraiment seuls
sur notre palier ou encore dans notre
ascenseur elles sont partout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en Chine on compte au moins une caméra
de surveillance pour deux habitants
[Musique]
des yeux électroniques qui nous
regardent en permanence
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Lulu veut me montrer la
dernière trouvaille de la mairie
en voiture ou en personne et après on te
fiches sur l'écran
sur l'écran c'est pour montrer tout le
monde d'ailleurs que tu as fait quelque
chose à interdit et ça sert plus tard tu
perds les points
d'afficher aussi c'est pareil c'est que
pour les piétons hein pour tout le monde
tu as vu tu as vu la fille qui traverse
les gens qui suivent les règles qui fait
pas des bêtises voilà
bah d'ailleurs quelque part c'est comme
on me prend comme comme des enfants
23 millions d'enfants à Pékin 1 milliard
400 millions en Chine
des enfants comme ma femme noté puni ou
récompensés selon leur comportement
une population tout entière placée sous
surveillance
des caméras dans les rues des
applications sur le téléphone portable
les fichiers des assurances le casier
judiciaire votre notation bancaire votre
dossier médical en Chine toutes les
données sont numériques instantanées
les villes intelligentes censées
utiliser la 5G et le Big Data pour
améliorer la vie locale sont en fait de
grands réseaux de surveillance
[Musique]
prendre le métro acheter à manger
choisir un livre tous les actes du
quotidien sont archivés par la grande
moissonneuse digitale la récolte est
faite par le régime qui mélange toutes
ces données pour construire le portrait
numérique de chaque citoyen
tous les Chinois ont désormais un double
digital qui vit sa vie dans les serveurs
informatiques de Pékin
un double noté calibré jugé par les
ordinateurs du parti
[Musique]
pour les citoyens ça ressemble à un jeu
ou à un programme de fidélité
la loyauté fait gagner des points les
critiques font baisser le crédit
[Musique]
voilà le quotidien de ma femme Lulu et
de ses compatriotes confrontés à ce
compteur qui juge leur vie chaque jour
chaque heure chaque seconde
ma femme n'est pas journaliste elle
travaille dans le marketing
c'est pour comprendre en quoi cette
révolution technologique et sociale
impacte sa vie que j'ai décidé de filmer
son quotidien
la journée a commencé et on peut pas
vivre sans téléphone ça commence déjà
avec smartphone il faut que je commande
un une voiture
le téléphone portable en Chine plus
encore qu'ailleurs dans le monde
impossible de s'en passer
le pays compte plus d'un milliard
d'abonnés
et rien n'échappe aux applications que
Lulu a installé sur son smartphone
qu'est-ce qu'on voit sur un application
on voit son nom le nom de trajets
quelle marque quelle couleur à la plaque
son nom et combien de trajets qu'il a
fait c'est combien de temps qu'il a son
permis
on va tout jusque là rien de vraiment
exceptionnel
cependant ici tout le trajet est filmé
et enregistré avec cette petite caméra
installée au-dessus du rétroviseur
pour le reste le fonctionnement est
identique à celui que nous connaissons
on note le chauffeur il nous note en
retour
[Musique]
en Chine la note est devenue la norme
comme partout sur la planète on
distribue des bons points à chaque
commande sur internet à chaque voyage en
train ou en avion on note en levant le
pouce sur les réseaux sociaux des
évaluations qui conditionnent la
popularité d'une personne où la
fiabilité d'une entreprise
mais sur la planète Chine toutes ces
interactions tous ces likes sont autant
de données qui sont recoupées entre
elles et regroupées dans un coffre-fort
digital dont le gouvernement à la clé
l'activité sur les réseaux sociaux mais
également les achats les déplacements
les conversations des vies privées
stockées dans un code installé par
chaque chinois sur son téléphone
portable
l'épidémie de covid-19 va permettre au
gouvernement d'ajouter cet outil
supplémentaire à son dispositif déjà
existant de collecte des données
le QR Code
son objectif officiel tracer les
déplacements et les contacts pour lutter
contre la propagation du virus
[Musique]
on s'en sert partout pour aller chez le
coiffeur prenez votre téléphone et
scanner celui-là il faut
se scanner celui du milieu
chaque bâtiment nous sommes entrés
chaque personne que nous avons croisé le
QR code connaît tout de nos faits et
gestes
car en Chine ce mouchard est installé au
sein même des applications sans
lesquelles il nous est impossible de
vivre
à l'IP une application de paiement
comparable à Apple P et développé par
Alibaba le concurrent d'Amazon
Taobao le site d'achat en ligne préféré
de Lulu
sans oublier le groupe Tencent
développeur de Witcher
le couteau suisse informatique avec
lequel on dialogue on paye on scanne à
tour de bras une sorte de WhatsApp
multitâche
[Musique]
toutes ces applications déployées par
les géants chinois de la tech sont des
aspirateurs de données personnelles des
données qui alimentent directement le
système de surveillance constant du
parti
[Musique]
j'ai rendez-vous avec fensoyan il est
data analyste la rencontre est fixée
dans un quartier très branché de Pékin
[Musique]
il va me confirmer que la crise
sanitaire a bien accéléré le système de
collecte de données directement via les
applications installées sur les
téléphones portables
comparons le système du code sanitaire à
un gâteau au début les ingénieurs les
inventeurs des entreprises de latex
comme Alibaba et Tencent arrivent avec
une idée une recette de gâteau il la
présente au gouvernement
seuls du gouvernement ont le droit de
demander les données personnelles comme
par exemple celle détenue par les
compagnies aériennes la compagnie de
chemin de fer ou de téléphonie mobile
ils ne peuvent utiliser ces informations
que sous certaines conditions le
gouvernement fournit donc les
ingrédients nécessaires au gâteau
mais pour mélanger les ingrédients et
préparer le gâteau seuls les compagnies
de la tech ont la capacité de le faire
le gouvernement n'est pas pâtissier
ensuite on va considérer que les
gouvernements ont le droit de demander
aux plateformes de paiement en ligne de
leur fournir les détails des
transactions sous certaines conditions
là aussi
la question c'est comment trouver un
équilibre entre la protection des
données personnelles et ce que le
gouvernement a le droit de faire cette
discussion aujourd'hui elle anime le
monde entier
mais le débat ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
dès la fin des années 80 le contrôle de
la population via la maîtrise des
données est introduit avec l'ouverture
de la Chine à l'économie de marché
[Musique]
le pays s'éveille au poulet frit aux
Ferrari et à l'argent
beaucoup d'argent
[Musique]
une petite musique démentie passion
rapidement mise en sourdine par le parti
10 enfants de Mao ne seront pas plus
libres
ils seront riches
en contrepartie de l'accession au bien
de consommation la vie des Chinois ne va
plus avoir aucun secret pour le parti
Pékin va réguler à sa manière les flux
financiers contrôler la consommation et
de ce fait les personnes
[Musique]
ma femme lulu est une enfant de la
grande consommation
et du téléphone portable
elle fait partie de ces chinois qui
achètent dépensent envisage des vacances
s'imaginent une retraite au soleil
depuis que le tribunal populaire du
commerce a placé la révolution en
liquidation sa génération profite du
grand boom
[Musique]
c'est sur cette soif de consommer que le
système de crédit financier chinois voit
le jour dans les années 80
mais avant pékin veut comprendre
comprendre cet étrange mécanique de
l'économie de marché et se familiariser
avec le crédit
[Musique]
cette histoire c'est shindai qui nous la
racontent il est professeur de droit à
l'Université shingroi de Pékin
l'université la plus réputée du pays
selon le cliché consacré en Occident la
Chine va copier ce qui se fait de mieux
à l'ouest
l'ancêtre du Crédit Social chinois et
made in
USA
l'histoire c'est que certains ont
fonctionnaires ont fait un voyage aux
États-Unis
était de comprendre pourquoi il n'y
avait pas autant de fraude sur le marché
américain que sur le marché chinois
ils ont découvert que les États-Unis
avaient mis en place un mécanisme appelé
système de crédit un système de notation
avec une loi qui régulée l'accès mais
aussi la valeur des crédits
si vous aviez commis une fraude lors
d'une transaction elle était enregistrée
dans votre dossier de crédit et donc
figurer dans votre dossier personnel du
coup si par la suite vous vouliez
souscrire un nouveau crédit ou bien
réalisé de nouvelles affaires l'incident
qui avait été rapporté été susceptible
de vous en empêcher vous n'étiez plus
digne de confiance
le parti va voir dans ces mécanismes de
régulation financière une opportunité de
contrôle beaucoup plus large
et si la solvabilité les habitudes des
consommateurs permettaient d'établir un
score
c'est alors que naît la tentation du
Crédit social
attribuer une note aux citoyens en
fonction de leur comportement d'achat
un système de bon et de mauvais points
pour atteindre l'idéal de la société
intègre et harmonieuse
un programme détaillé dans le plan
quinquennal et rendu public par le
gouvernement chinois des juin 2014 dans
ce document
[Musique]
le système de crédit social est un
élément important du système d'économie
de marché socialiste et du système de
gouvernance sociale
les incitations à la fiabilité et les
contraintes non dignes de confiance sont
utilisés comme récompenses et punitions
[Musique]
l'accélération de la construction d'un
système de crédit social est une base
importante pour la mise en oeuvre
complète du concept de développement
technologique et la construction d'une
société socialiste harmonieuse
un système dans lequel les informations
financières seraient recoupées avec le
comportement civique une note de vie
créant un nouvel ordre social avec des
citoyens de première seconde troisième
ou quatrième classe
days
vous pourrez utiliser ces points pour
bénéficier d'accès privilégiés à
certains services publics
par exemple vous pourriez être admis à
l'hôpital public sans avoir à verser de
caution
la même chose pour aller consulter un
médecin vous pourriez être capable
d'aller dans certains parcs sans payer
le ticket d'entrée
vous pourriez accéder à des bons de
réduction en utilisant les transports
publics tout ce genre de choses je pense
que dans certaines villes vous pourriez
aller à la bibliothèque publique et
emprunter des ouvrages sans avoir là
aussi à laisser une caution grâce à
votre bonne note pour le moment ce sont
ces types davantage dont vous pourriez
bénéficier mais c'est assez insignifiant
pour le moment
et ma femme dans tout ça Lulu a-t-elle
suffisamment de crédit aux yeux du
gouvernement
[Musique]
en tout cas c'est une bonne élève son
compteur affiche 5 points de plus 5
petits points de gagner sans doute grâce
à ses bonnes habitudes de consommation
son sens civique et son respect des
règles
shindai va analyser sa note
[Musique]
on voit que vous pouvez faire pas mal de
choses vous voyez pour l'hébergement
avec la note que vous avez vous pouvez
loger dans ces différents hôtels en
étant exempté de cautions on les
transports vous pouvez bénéficier de
réduction et même cela maintenant
regardez c'est très intéressant les
visas pour le Canada l'Argentine et la
Lettonie
cela ne veut pas dire qu'avec ça vous
pouvez vous procurer un visage ambassade
du Canada sans fournir de documents
personnels mais comme votre note atteint
un certain niveau vous n'aurez pas
besoin de fournir certains documents à
l'ambassade
mais cela ne signifie pas qu'on peut
obtenir un visa uniquement avec une
bonne note ce n'est pas pensable
et bon maintenant cette note peut-être
utile elle peut être recevable auprès
des ambassades
pour Lulu c'est la promesse d'une plus
grande facilité de déplacement
grâce au bon score affiché sur son
application
Soshi of the good score Judas
[Musique]
bon Lulu n'est pas effrayé comme moi de
ce monde 100 % digital d'une société où
personne ne peut se cacher
[Musique]
où tous les gestes du quotidien sont
analysés interprétés stockés
[Musique]
ou un téléphone portable peut faire de
nous des bons ou des mauvais citoyens
c'est pas coller mais
[Musique]
est-ce que tu t'inquiètes un peu de
bouffer qu'on puisse te surveiller aussi
avec le téléphone parce que
qui n'a pas
de mal si il veut savoir si quelqu'un
vas-y pour l'instant
je préfère vivre avec ça ou tu préfères
refuser
pourquoi on refuse on peut pas refuser
maintenant
je refuse pas c'est tellement pratique
ça ramène une vie
facile tu coupes tu peux plus tu peux
plus
tu peux plus quitter les entreprises qui
ont fabriqué wechat et réalité elles
savent tout de toi
est-ce que tu as plus peur de ces
entreprises ou tu as plus peur de l'État
qui te suit
on peut pas
dire peur on peut dire des quelques fois
c'est un peu en
quiétant tu fais une blague un peu con
des fois si tu touches les sujets
politiques ça peut ça peut vite faire
quelqu'un t'appelle pour des groupes
non j'ai pas changé la façon de ma vie
j'ai pas changé
[Musique]
la suivante va-t-on faire marche arrière
et revenir à l'époque où nous n'avions
pas de smartphone une époque où il n'y
avait pas de caméra
et si le sens de l'histoire c'était
d'accepter tout ça si on décidait de
faire avec vous savez tout évolue toutes
ces données et cette surveillance nous
apporte des choses positives ça par
exemple une plus grande sécurité une
plus grande sûreté une meilleure
efficacité
c'est ce que les gens désirent avoir
aujourd'hui à la condition que certaines
valeurs ne soient pas perdue ou bien
alors
nous devons faire avec
la population a-t-elle réellement le
choix
dispose-t-elle d'autres alternatives que
d'accepter les nouvelles conditions
générales de vie imposées par le régime
mais après tout comme le dit Lulu tu
sens que c'est pratique la logique de
surveillance globale accompagne
systématiquement les mutations de la
société chinoise en s'appuyant sur les
progrès de la technologie
[Musique]
c'est le cas avec la disparition d'une
espèce apparue au 11e siècle en Chine le
billet de banque
petit à petit à Pékin les billets par
nature anonyme disparaissent au profit
du paiement sans contact parfaitement
traçable par le régime et ironie de
cette histoire à chaque coupure qui est
retirée de la circulation c'est le
visage de Mao qui s'efface un peu plus
du quotidien des Chinois
incroyable lorsque je me souviens que
jusqu'aux années 2010 je devais tout
régler en liquide
et que mes cartes de crédit étrangères
n'étaient quasiment jamais accepté
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la télévision d'État fait
même la publicité de cette société
auprès des étrangers
un monde où tout est plus facile pour
peu que l'on accepte en échange de
n'avoir aucun secret pour le parti
mais une technologie bien plus avancée
sans vie dans notre quotidien à Lulu et
à moi
alors
qu'est-ce que tu veux
comme ça ça va
cela ou cela
c'est beaucoup plus cher
on paye avec la tête
et voici le paiement à la tête du client
avec la reconnaissance faciale
c'est ça est-ce que tu sais comment ils
connaissent ta tête
j'ai posé la question comment ça se fait
que quand tu peux payer avec ton visage
ou avec QR code et comment il reconnaît
ton visage tu penses
c'est enregistré quand tu enregistré à
l'épée il y a scanner dans la tête c'est
enregistré dans le système de paiement
ça fait bizarre non non ça fait très
drôle
ça fait drôle
[Musique]
nom prénom adresse numéro de téléphone
déplacement historique d'achat et
désormais visage toutes ces données sont
compilées associées agrégées
au final pas sûr que tout cela soit si
drôle
sur chaque visage le parti peut
désormais lire toute l'intimité de la
vie privée des Chinois
un outil de surveillance de masse au
centre des investissements du
gouvernement chinois
au fil des ans Pékin va gagner son
indépendance technologique et
s'affranchir des entreprises étrangères
dans le domaine de la reconnaissance
faciale et de l'intelligence
artificielle
[Musique]
chez inan et le vice-président de mecs
cette licorne chinoise est l'un des
leaders mondiaux de la reconnaissance
faciale une technologie vendue notamment
à la police
un système pouvant identifier en temps
réel un individu via les caméras de
vidéosurveillance
ce logiciel complexe de reconnaissance
faciale le voici dans cette vidéo
promotionnelle réalisée à la manière
d'une bande annonce hollywoodienne
[Musique]
monsieur Lee un délinquant financier en
fuite depuis 2016 a été repéré par le
Sky High et la police averti
après vérification il a pu être
rapidement arrêté
nous appelons cela le cerveau de la
ville d'un côté il y a un usage privé et
de l'autre un usage sécuritaire contrôlé
par la police nous travaillons déjà avec
27 provinces chinoises pour assurer leur
sécurité et notre technologie a permis
d'arrêter plus de 3000 délinquants
ce programme appelé Smart ice les yeux
intelligents s'intègrent dans un projet
beaucoup plus global un réseau baptisé
Skynet
un clin d'oeil au système d'intelligence
artificielle qui prend le contrôle de la
planète dans le film Terminator
l'objectif est de pouvoir identifier
n'importe qui n'importe où grâce à des
centaines de millions de caméras de
surveillance
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous pouvons réunir des
éléments importants sur les véhicules
comme sur les personnes y compris des
caractéristiques particulières le type
de véhicule la coiffure des gens les
vêtements qu'ils portent s'ils sont à
vélo s'il transporte un sac tous ces
détails peuvent être enregistrés
tout cela permet d'analyser tout ce qui
se passerait réellement dans la ville
quotidiennement par exemple dans cette
rue on peut savoir quel type de voiture
circule à quel moment la circulation se
transforme par exemple s'il y a des
bouchons ou bien un accident quel est le
type prédominant de personnes qui
empruntent cette rue ainsi si l'on a
besoin de savoir ce qui s'est passé à un
moment donné et quel type de personne
était présente c'est très facile à
savoir c'est cela que nous appelons le
Sky High urbain
des informations et une technologie qui
permettent aussi de prédire d'anticiper
le comportement des individus dans
l'espace public et tout ça grâce au Big
Data et à l'intelligence artificielle
[Musique]
on estime que la recherche chinoise en
matière d'intelligence artificielle
aurait deux décennies d'avance sur ses
concurrents directs
je prends la direction de l'université
de chinois pour y rencontrer le
professeur souganda l'un des chercheurs
qui a le plus contribué aux travaux de
développement de cette technologie dès
le début des années 2000
lors des JO de Pékin en 2008 le
gouvernement chinois a été le premier à
utiliser la reconnaissance faciale
c'était la première fois au monde
qu'elle était employée dans des
circonstances olympiques
l'Exposition Universelle ainsi que de
nombreux événements réclamant un très
haut niveau de sécurité on peut utiliser
la reconnaissance faciale
cela a été possible grâce au soutien
important de l'État
élève le niveau de la sécurité publique
c'est pourquoi la population peut vivre
dans une société harmonieuse une société
plus sûre c'est pourquoi la
reconnaissance faciale doit recevoir le
soutien de la population elle a beaucoup
d'avantages il y a des compagnies qui
ont des données individuelles sur plus
de 100 millions de personnes si la
reconnaissance faciale connaît une telle
réussite c'est parce que la masse des
données est immense
et le volume de données devrait encore
augmenter au fur et à mesure des
avancées sur la reconnaissance faciale
on dit que maintenant en plus du visage
on peut aussi identifier les gens à
partir de leur mouvement
[Musique]
ou encore l'iris ou bien sur d'autres
mouvements mais pour l'instant le taux
de reconnaissance par les mouvements est
encore bas et nous ne sommes pas au
niveau d'une utilisation réelle
ça reste une technologie très utile pour
la construction de ville plus sûre d'une
Chine plus sûre
[Musique]
reconnaître les gens prédire leur
comportement contrôler et observer leur
quotidien la surveillance a toujours été
la raison d'être de l'État parti
dès 1949 et la naissance de la
République populaire de Chine Pékin va
avoir des yeux partout
commissaire politique comité de quartier
ils vont être les yeux et les oreilles
de la sécurité publique au plus près de
la population
un maillage pensé pour un peuple qui ne
voyage pas pour un pays claque muret
fermé aux étrangers
[Musique]
mais la société chinoise va changer elle
va se déplacer
d'une ville à l'autre d'une région à
l'autre d'un pays à l'autre
là aussi le parti à la solution pour
maintenir sa surveillance effective
[Musique]
bonjour
aujourd'hui nous partons en weekend à
Shanghai à 1300 km de Pékin
lulu a réservé son voyage via alipé
l'une des applications installées sur
son smartphone
757 c'est les points
ma femme est une bonne cliente bien
notée son crédit est suffisamment élevé
pour que sa commande aboutisse
[Musique]
nous prenons la direction de la grande
gare du Sud l'une des trois que compte
la capitale
et là vous vous dites que prendre les
transports en Chine il n'y a rien de
plus facile
[Musique]
mais lorsque ma femme a réservé son
billet de train l'application n'a pas
seulement interrogé son solde à la
banque à l'IP est allé bien plus loin
l'ensemble des détails de la vie privée
et sociale de Lulu comme celle de tous
ses compatriotes son numérisés sur son
téléphone
[Musique]
la tête pour rentrer dans la gare et
encore une fois pour accéder au train et
c'est terminé
l'application a recoupé une somme de
données bien plus large et la autoriser
à acheter son billet et donc à se
déplacer
[Musique]
et
si vous avez été placé sur la liste
noire après avoir commis un délit ou
bien que vous avez été jugé par un
tribunal comme étant un mauvais payeur
dans un litige financier
le jugement est publié sur le site
internet du tribunal
cette liste noire peuvent aussi être
communiqués aux compagnies ferroviaires
ou aux autoritaires alors ils ont accès
à toutes ces informations et donc quand
vous voulez acheter un billet de train
ou d'avion vous devez fournir votre
numéro d'identité c'est comme ça qu'il
vous attrape
[Musique]
dans le train Lulu va continuer
d'alimenter son crédit en dépensant via
son application
[Musique]
toujours le QR Code
encore de la reconnaissance faciale
[Musique]
et une fois de plus autant de données
transmises au serveur d'Ali p
ma femme soigne son crédit et demeure
une bonne citoyenne sa plus grande
crainte passée sous le seuil des 350
points et venir grossir la liste des
citoyens de seconde zone
[Musique]
à notre arrivée à l'hôtel le scénario se
répète cet hôtel de Shanghai nous avons
pu y réserver une chambre grâce à la
bonne note de Lulu
un mauvais crédit et une inscription sur
la liste noire et ce type
d'établissement nous aurait alors été
interdit
cette liste noire c'est le cœur du
réacteur du grand projet de crédit
social c'est l'algorithme
ultime prêt à être déployé à tout moment
par l'État parti chinois un système dont
lequel le comportement vertueux est
encouragé et récompensé pour ceux qui
franchissent la ligne la sanction est
immédiate et faite aussitôt baisser la
note et c'est peut-être là la plus
grande victoire du parti réguler les
comportements sans avoir besoin de
sortir le bâton
certaines lois disent que le système du
Crédit Social est pensé pour améliorer
l'efficacité de la réglementation du
marché
mais aussi promouvoir les bonnes valeurs
la question est toujours de savoir
comment utiliser ce système
honnêtement vous pouvez l'utiliser on
pourrait écrire une étude sociologique
bien évidemment vous pouvez dire avec ce
système les gens se soucient davantage
de ce qu'ils disent de ce à quoi il
s'engage et donc s'y tiendront il
deviendront
plus honnête et surtout plus respectueux
des règles
et ça commence par bien savoir traverser
dans les clous les réfractaires à cette
idéale de société harmonieuse ne peuvent
plus se cacher
[Applaudissements]
la tête sur la grande écran ça fait peur
[Musique]
ça et maintenant tu scannes ta tête
partout après imagine tu as mauvais
point quoi
au milieu de la rue ici c'est bizarre
là on voit derrière
respecte-moi
la photo sur grand l'écran c'est la
honte quoi
on essaie de traverser au rouge pour
voir ah non je fais pas ça moi
je traverse
tu vas essayer vas-y pas moi
sur l'écran
ça va être un festival pour toi
si on t'enlève des points ou si pour
l'instant c'est juste envisager
c'est la grosse honte c'est la grosse
honte
pour garantir l'efficacité de ce
contrôle permanent de l'espace public et
des individus un outil est indispensable
la caméra de surveillance
elle se généralise en Chine dès le début
des années 2000
surveillance du domicile des entreprises
des magasins il y en a partout dans les
vins villes les plus équipées au monde
de caméras de surveillance 18 sont
chinoises
chunching 31 millions d'habitants compte
une caméra pour 6 habitants
Shanghai 26 millions une pour 9 en
comparaison Nice la ville française la
plus équipée compte une caméra pour 130
habitants
une société sous surveillance dont il
est quasiment impossible de se
soustraire dans les yeux du Big Brother
chinois sont partout
[Musique]
dans l'espace public impossible pour
Lulu d'échapper à la dictature de la
note sociale
l'anonymat s'efface de la société
chinoise
le Crédit Social s'immis jusque dans la
sphère la plus intime
en fonction de ce qu'elle consomme de
son régime alimentaire la note de Lulu
pourrait être revue à la baisse
c'est l'avènement du citoyen saint
[Musique]
dans un corps sain
e
imagine si en fonction de ce que tu
achètes tu peux gagner ou tu peux perdre
des points
des fois en buvant du thé forcément et
on va perdre des points par exemple en
buvant de l'alcool j'avais pris une
petite bière tu auras perdu
[Musique]
tu prends un burger ou à des frites
voilà et peut-être il t'enlève pas les
points mais au moins c'est noté quoi tu
vis pas en bonne santé du coup il faut
boire du thé
[Musique]
tu veux quoi toi
si ton crédit pouvait enregistrer en
fonction de ce que tu manges ce serait
bien parce que ça t'obligerait à mieux
manger
mais des fois on a quand même besoin à
faire plaisir
nous-mêmes on peut pas on peut pas vivre
avec un ordre comme ça quoi c'est si ça
rentre dans le truc nous réduire de ce
que tu manges tous les jours ça peut tu
consommes tous les jours c'est une vie
de prisonnière
c'est comme tu es en prison il t'a
ramène un plateau tu as pas le choix si
tu manges pas tu as faim ou tu mens mais
quand même on est des humains
[Musique]
Lulu n'est pas franchement décidé à
conditionner son existence en fonction
des interdits et non plus de ses envies
ou de ses aspirations
mais alors qu'il n'est pas encore
entièrement déployé le Crédit Social
s'impose déjà dans les esprits comme le
nouveau logiciel de pensée
mais on va où
[Musique]
premier deuxième troisième
acheter les trois tomes de la vision
politique du président chinois ou encore
un récit à géographique consacré à chez
Jinping
rapporterait combien de points au Crédit
Social de ma femme
acquérir un exemplaire des poèmes de Mao
Zeitung ou une biographie autorisée de
dencia hoping c'est le rayon politique
tout de suite à l'entrée en fait
permettre est-il à Lulu d'accéder au
Graal des 950 points du citoyen modèle
je sais pas qu'est-ce que c'est interdit
déjà
du coup
c'est très sage
je suis quelqu'un normal
[Musique]
un modèle de société régie entièrement
par les normes le score et le Crédit
social
[Musique]
cette vie privée en open space certains
chinois la rejette et la dénonce
[Musique]
aujourd'hui avec Lulu nous avons
rendez-vous dans la banlieue nord de
Pékin
est un artiste engagé son combat est
celui de la protection des données et la
dénonciation de l'emprise du Big Data
sur la vie privée
difficile de connaître la note sociale
de dingue mais ces prises de position
font certainement de lui un mauvais
client voire un débiteur du régime
ces tracts jaunes sont sa dernière
performance artistique
qu'est-ce que vous voulez montrer avec
cet acte
représente tous les secrets que je
possède en tant qu'être humain mais ses
secrets sont rendus publics puis imprimé
sur ce document
c'est une sorte de CV sur ce CV figure
quelques informations de base et même
des mots de passe bancaires celui de mon
compte wechat et quelques autres détails
beaucoup plus privés comme des secrets
le 18 mars 2021 daigne est accompagné de
trois volontaires et encadré par une
grappe de journalistes occidentaux
il distribue au passant ces tracts
d'immortalité sur les avenues et dans
les rues du quartier 7 9 8 de Pékin un
quartier où se trouve de nombreux
ateliers d'artistes
en Chine dénoncer latinte à la vie
privée la dictature de la grande
faucheuse numérique des géants de la
tech est un exercice dangereux
les prospectus jaune de dingue vont
envoyer l'artiste directement au poste
de police
et sans nul doute faire baisser encore
un peu plus sa note de crédit social
ils avaient des agents de sécurité enfin
quelque chose qui s'en approche ils ont
dû appeler la police juste après au
final j'ai été arrêté et emprisonné
durant 24 heures
déjà en octobre 2020 l'artiste avait
fait parler de lui
il tente une expérience pour montrer aux
pekinois comment échapper à l'oeil de la
surveillance
[Musique]
effectuer un parcours dans une rue de
Pékin sans jamais entrer dans le champ
d'une caméra
Dang passe deux mois à mesurer la rue
[Musique]
il la photographie sous toutes les
coutures
détails les modèles des 90 caméras
repères le remplacement mais aussi leur
champ de vision
[Musique]
à peu près la toux fait c'est un travail
de technicien aussi en même temps
le jour J accompagné d'un petit groupe
de volontaires il remonte la rue en fil
indienne tête baissée accroupi le petit
groupe avant sente lentement
il descend du trottoir rase les murs se
cache derrière des panneaux
publicitaires
au total ils auront mis deux heures pour
faire un peu plus d'un kilomètre
pour moi ça parle de la manière dont
l'état gère le problème
cette question est celle de la façon
dont l'État a décidé
d'agirons moi j'ai choisi la manière
forte
j'ai voulu marquer les esprits car dans
ce pays les gens nous y compris vous et
moi nous n'avons pas de connaissance
juridique nous ne savons pas vraiment
quels sont nos droits
nous ne sommes pas sensibilisés aux
questions juridiques de confidentialité
dans ce cas là vous pouvez utiliser des
moyens plus efficaces pour sensibiliser
les gens et peut-être obtenir plus
rapidement un résultat
mais le combat de dingue semble perdu
d'avance
Pékin contrôle l'activité des géants de
la tech et son droit de regard est
d'utilisation sur les données n'est
jamais remise en cause
[Musique]
Alibaba
sont les créatures du parti
[Musique]
des colosses sans lesquels le
gouvernement chinois n'aurait jamais pu
se constituer un tel arsenal de
surveillance
[Musique]
mais ce que la raison d'État demande la
raison d'État comment en Chine
[Musique]
et il n'y a personne pour contrôler le
parti
[Musique]
reste Lulu ma femme et son crédit
comment Lulu imagine-t-elle son monde et
le nôtre dans 20 ans
ce matin nous quittons notre résidence
de Pékin toujours sous l'oeil des
caméras de surveillance tiens d'ailleurs
celle-là n'était pas là hier soir
c'est la dernière étape de ce voyage
entamé il y a un an avec Lulu
[Musique]
qu'elle regarde ma femme chinoise
porte-t-elle sur cette société qui lui
promet une vie à crédit
une vie dont elle est devenue la cliente
idéale
les nouveaux technologies est-ce
que sont les contrôler et utiliser dans
les bons sens est-ce que on a
assouplissant assez fort pour contrôler
tous ces
logiciels nouveaux technologies on sait
pas on sait pas du coup ça fait
réfléchir
[Musique]
tout ce que tu fais tout ce que tu
parles tu penses d'abord est-ce que j'ai
le droit où j'ai pas le doigt qu'est-ce
que je peux avoir comme point et moi
enlever le point il va il va nous faire
quelque chose de pas bien et du coup on
est en train de se garer comme ça comme
une carie chacun ils sont en train de
nous manger les cerveaux
et on a en train de nous former comme
des robots on peut dire
[Musique]
imagine les enfants qui sont nés
aujourd'hui et dans 20 ans
ils seront des adultes et
comment il peut être les gens qui sont
nés aujourd'hui ils vont avoir ils vont
être moitié repos en arrière mais
toujours avec le look de humain
alors je te propose Lulu c'est qu'on se
donne rendez-vous dans 20 ans et puis on
verra si ça a évolué comme tu le penses
si on devient tous des robots j'espère
pas tu peux donner encore le camarade
[Musique]
mais l'histoire semble d'ores et déjà
écrite
pour vivre dans ce nouveau modèle de
société ma femme ne devrait pas avoir à
patienter bien longtemps
Pékin a le doigt sur le bouton celui du
lancement de sa société harmonieuse et
de la mise sur orbite du Crédit social
Lulu n'est pas prête de quitter des yeux
le petit conteur de son téléphone
portable
[Musique]